[Música]
i
como comienza el camino hacia un
objetivo en la vida básicamente en la
mía siempre ha iniciado con un lápiz y
un papel mi vida en el sector financiero
arranca cuando un ex jefe hace más de 20
años me pide que hagamos el ejercicio de
dibujar el mapa de mi carrera en ese
momento tenía un enorme ímpetu unas
ganas enormes de hacer cosas muchas
ideas desordenadas y probablemente lo
estaba volviendo loco nos sentamos a
hacer un ejercicio muy detallado que
tardó más de tres horas donde él me hizo
muchas preguntas para las cuales en
muchas ocasiones
yo no tenía una respuesta después de
este proceso logramos llegar con
claridad a entender que mi objetivo era
generar un impacto en las personas las
herramientas con las que contaba era esa
enorme energía el enfocó en que las
cosas sucedan y a partir de ahí nos
dimos cuenta que mi foco iba a estar en
trabajar en la banca comercial primero
en la privada donde ya estaba luego en
la banca pública hoy estoy en el banco
central y el siguiente paso que
dibujamos no se los voy a contar para
que no se sale como diría mi abuela
después de hacer todo ese ejercicio que
hoy veo hacia atrás como una enorme
claridad ustedes podrán creer que
realmente me quedé pensando que había
perdido miserablemente tres horas de mi
vida
pero de qué vamos a hablar hoy realmente
el tema de hoy es la transformación
digital y estoy segura que cuando yo les
hable de transformación digital todos
los que están viendo se van a separar en
dos grupos uno el que dice que
interesante este tema y el segundo grupo
en el que definitivamente estaría yo el
que dice otro más hablando de lo mismo
a través de mis más de 20 años en el
sector financiero
he visto experiencias de cambio que han
sido fracasos estrepitosos
repetirse una y otra vez he visto
procesos de automatización originados en
una observación de auditoría que vio una
hoja de excel que no le hizo gracia y
gastamos miles de dólares logrando que
eso se convirtiera en un pseudo sistema
he visto experiencias de
implementaciones de srm que se supone
que son herramientas que le permiten a
una organización
centralizar la relación con sus clientes
que nunca ven la luz o que vean la luz y
se convierten en un archivo muy caro
he visto una experiencia grande de un
esfuerzo de toda una organización
enfocada en lograr un proceso de
innovación con herramientas caras un
equipo a cargo todos los líderes
enfocados en el tema del cual no salen
ni siquiera cinco ideas implementables
que tengan algún impacto financiero para
la organización
todo esto son experiencias tristes de
cambio ahora imagínense cuando estamos
hablando de un proceso de transformación
tomamos el tema un poco a la ligera la
transformación de una compañía o de una
organización no es un proceso sencillo
no es contratar un consultor
internacional que nos diga qué hacer no
es nombrar un grupo no es nombrar un
comité no es nombrar un líder no es
mandar a alguien a un curso para que se
capacite nada de eso es realmente
transformación
hace unos pocos días se estaba
escuchando una entrevista de un
periodista a un ingeniero de la nasa
donde le decía que quería que le
comentara porque la gente cuando habla
de temas sencillos se refiere a que ese
tema no es un no es ciencia de cohetes
él hay una respuesta muy pragmática pero
que para mí es muy clara y nos da una
línea de cara a un proceso de
transformación y lo que le contesto es
yo no puedo decirle la respuesta a esa
pregunta porque yo lo que soy es un
ingeniero no soy un científico y mi
único objetivo es sacar un cohete de la
atmósfera sin que exploten a un costo
razonable
eso es lo que debería ser la
transformación para nosotros ahora como
solo les he contado experiencias tristes
les voy a contar una experiencia feliz
me imagino que todos ustedes conocen el
simple móvil el simple móvil es una
maravilla y ha venido a transformar la
vida de muchos pequeños empresarios en
el país y de muchas personas que hoy
pueden mover su dinero fácilmente de una
manera
ustedes creen que el banco central
contrató para este proceso de creación
de simple móvil unos consultores
internacionales que vinieron y le
dijeron cómo hacer la fórmula perfecta
para desarrollar este sistema que para
agosto ya va a generar 20 millones de
transacciones pues no los que se
imaginan que eso fue lo que sucedió
están muy equivocados en el banco
central hace más de 20 años se hicieron
una pregunta muy sencilla cuál es el
principal problema que tenemos nosotros
hoy en día y la respuesta fue hay un
enorme costo transaccional que enfrentan
los ciudadanos de cara al uso del
efectivo y a partir de esas hicieron una
segunda pregunta qué podemos hacer para
solucionar esto y de ahí nace la idea
del simple que en sus inicios permitió
realizar transacciones electrónicas
entre instituciones financieras
quien le permitió al banco central
llegar desde ahí a lo que hoy es simple
móvil el objetivo siempre estuvo claro
el objetivo siempre ha sido disminuir el
costo transaccional de la ciudadanía las
herramientas para poder lograrlo han
mejorado definitivamente hace 20 años ni
siquiera teníamos teléfonos inteligentes
por lo cual la idea no era simple pero
al estar el objetivo claro las
herramientas sólo han venido a acompañar
al banco en la implementación de
soluciones para alcanzar ese objetivo
entonces qué es lo que necesitamos
nosotros realmente para poder tener un
proceso de transformación digital en las
organizaciones
necesitamos un lápiz y un papel
necesitamos olvidarnos de las
metodologías de moda de las herramientas
de moda de los nombres de las personas
que están de moda necesitamos enfocarnos
en cuál es el objetivo que estamos
persiguiendo con el proceso de
transformación digital
necesitamos que ese objetivo esté basado
en nuestros clientes
no vaya a ser que diseñemos algo
lindísimo pero que al cliente no le
funcione necesitamos asegurarnos que
estamos pensando en ellos no en nosotros
mismos
necesitamos entonces sentarnos a hacer
un proceso de planificación detallada no
vayamos a pensar como me pasó a mí al
final de aquel proceso de tres horas que
habíamos perdido el tiempo planificar es
una inversión nunca va a ser un gasto
necesitamos asegurarnos de saber cuál es
el camino que queremos tomar para lograr
ese proceso de lo contrario lo único que
les puedo asegurar es que van a tener un
proceso de transformación fallido que
les va a costar mucho tiempo mucho
dinero y lo principal que les va a hacer
perder credibilidad tanto dentro de la
organización como de cara a sus clientes
que necesitamos entonces para un proceso
de transformación digital exitoso muy
sencillo necesitamos hacer preguntas
necesitamos asegurarnos de tomar el
tiempo suficiente para llegar a las
respuestas necesitamos no saltar a la
respuesta necesitamos asegurarnos que
los clientes nos validan esas
conclusiones a las que nosotros llegamos
que necesitamos entonces en resumen para
poder lograr un proceso de
transformación digital exitoso muy
sencillo devolvamos a las raíces
necesitamos un lápiz y un papel
necesitamos enfocarnos en qué es lo que
queremos lograr con este proceso de
transformación necesitamos enfocarnos en
saber cómo le vamos a hacer llegar
nuestras soluciones a los clientes
necesitamos olvidarnos de todo lo que
rodea la palabra transformación digital
y enfocarnos en lo que realmente
significa
y si no lo único que les puedo
garantizar es que van a perder plata y
si algo se después de 20 años es que a
los banqueros no nos gusta perder plata
muchas gracias
ah
[Música]